it's the player break in the world of
counter-strike which means if you're
anything like us you're craving some
good old-fashioned csgo action to keep
you - til the break is over we put
together a list of our picks for the top
10 knife skills in csgo history we've
seen plenty of knife skills to stop it
defuse but Canadians comes in a number
10 for its clutch faster and it's
precision no flailing stabs here just
one solid blow we needed because the
ball puzzle buddy can't get it with a
knife Katie goes big at number 9 we have
convicts infamous knife skills from the
e League major it was so damn risky but
so damn sweet one HP versus two there's
3 HP between two players left in a 1vs1
post plant overtime of an elimination
matching convict Mike in the upper hand
take your time take your time
my dog injury and overtime that is bull
why would you do that these comes flying
in at number eight with a shot to the
leg and a stab to the chest to put
simple in the ground they don't were
these each door other each other are and
that also means the deuce could start to
probe it exactly where simple as CD I
mean to get their passage up down like
so no Scott
she has to do something because he can't
get the gun drawn in time forest mid
doors hold comes in at number 7 an
office easy and a knife to cap it off
full arsenal kills don't get much better
than this take down specifics what a big
kill and he's got the deep that out goes
for more take the free he's ready with
the OB scope throwing knife oh my god
thanks sound advice he's gettin at
gutted and well you won't you have a
forest plane like that there's not much
to say really you know it's pretty hard
to retake a fight when you have a guy
like this holding the double door is not
you people continuing the legacy of
insanely risky knife skills he
backstabbed his way to number 6 with his
ot winning kill from the recent ppl
major you piece to back off repeat if
you thought it's a shot on golfy
don't fool about pull down to 12 because
we got 12 a treaty one track 14 is the
choice you got it
geek boy the piggy goes to the
man take that sticky broke the back of a
risky play with it on magnificent in
that water plenty of knife kills our
sneekybeeky Bipasha stealthy stabbing a
fox comes in at number five for pure
savagery shadow to James for the great
casting fine books as creeping is
looking to see if you can find more
players very small strong K from Pasha
when is he going to pull the trigger or
will he pull out the night a precision
in oh my god the precision incision is
there
the latter system Aragog a number four
who could forget the insane wannabe one
between Kenny s and Guardian because
when a gun failed a knife can get it
done is he going to try and go huge in
Kenny ants on fight straight in his face
doesn't it
go play and make it three Nobby Oh Lord
that I was putting all that I can yet
speaking up so many kills in that route
we all know simple for his insane plays
and that means his flying knife from MLG
Columbus come within a number three
insult to injury indeed everyone taking
down get the trumpeter dog up there
simple of course stop him straight in
the chest and take them down this insult
or injury this guy is having an absolute
dream of a much gum why not mmm knife
kills are rare which means double knife
skills are even rarer but device shows
us what can happen when you bring a
knife to a pistol right nice cool gonna
win off and then there is a knife
because of item background device we're
doing one round that's insane
replan device right now what the hell
just happened that because ivamos okay
whatever
there's one keep going why not boom oh
my gosh tapping off our list the
hilarious 1v1 between envy pay and
pleasure
takes the number one spot the reaction
of the crowd and the casters tell you
all you need to know about this
amazingly memorable moment i'm not be so
what's happening
capi double-kill and envy they take the
pistol where it's pandemonium and look
at this moment poke Blair's running out
of ammo on the platform and indicate
making the note that amazing stuff and
what a brilliant start and those were
our picks for the top 10 knife skills in
csgo history did we miss a crazy knife
skill that you want to see drop us a
comment below thanks for watching if you
want more great content be sure to hit
that subscribe button
[Music]